[Music]
have you guys been going to the beach or
like spending time in the water and your
bathing suits and stuff
yeah is that the count is that that
counts
is that the count i did lake water pool
water beach water
nice and then you guys all have like the
swim shorts like boxer
kind of swimsuit or not boxers like
shorts like shorts we have swim shorts
we have various kinds of shorts i got
shorts that's what they're called
various patterns board shorts
swimming trunks i don't have trouble
speedo that's beetles yeah why you got
speedos
because if you really if you really want
to go fast you need to have speedos
really i played water polo you did yeah
cool did you play water polo yeah for a
year all day
yeah high school you're a beast in the
world um
i played goalie whoa yeah can you
treasure
above water and i was like so like
goalies like you have
a good goalie right like the thing is
this big so from trading water
you have to like you have to be able to
come out of the wat like a good goal
like this
you're um yeah yeah honey you one one
leg's going this way the other is going
like a good goalie can get your entire
torso
out of the water and stay in this
position yes i was not the main goalie
though
but i could swim fast still to this day
whoa
i want to see you swim you got to come
over and you swim with your head
out yeah it's different yeah it's like
and then you have to get an erection and
use that as a third spinner
spinners third leg and it scares the
other team away
three spinners one leg going faster than
the other oh yeah do you
i mean you you can was i
yeah maybe i just my brain
working correctly right now okay or
outwards actually outwards
stick this outwards it depends what the
where you're going come on
not at the same time yeah if you go like
this it's back if you go like this it's
front
this is look you can go both the way i
tread is more of like i'm just trying to
survive the best i can for as long as i
can
yeah yeah anyway what do you ask yes uh
because i wanted to learn how to tread
just kidding no because
you would have tread lightly these two
friends from
toronto
these two friends from toronto they uh
they are doing this bathing suit
revolution
and they created this invention called
the brokini
oh huh is it like pants with just
dick showing what do you think um i
think it's like a v
but it it already like the bar yeah like
that
is that what okay okay any other brokini
um i think it's like assless chaps i'm
thinking speedo but yeah
more ass cheeks oh is it like overalls
before the water
overalls oh okay i don't see it i cannot
wait
so this is their ad
[Music]
hey that's a singlet i think there's
been plenty of advancements
yeah those are nice they're stretchy now
like
oh no give you the confidence careful
kids
commercial or just kind of like the
clothes we used to come up with
is it for real or is it a gag thing both
really it's so for real gekko it started
off as a joke on not about money
well it's funny because this is what
their about section says
it says we the founders excelled in high
school and found classes
to be a joke we therefore didn't develop
any work or study ethic and spent most
of our time playing hacky sack and sword
fighting with meter sticks
we somehow made it into business it's
tight and we were both perfectly
mediocre and that is why we are stuck
running a business that loses money like
crazy
that's tight we hope to one day grow
brokinis enough to cover our
massive cryptocurrency losses and hire a
golden retriever
receptionist but we have no idea how to
run a business so that seems pretty
unlikely at this point
we like dogs and strawberry daiquiris
and the toronto maple leaves
sounds like us but we actually got to
keep a little money
yeah and then they finish it with if you
want to learn more please go to the
brokini product page and click
add to cart does it exist i'm going to
support them i do too i want to support
them it does
yeah this is a comment i feel like
they're my little bros i got to support
them there's points on this
how much does it cost to make i love the
attitude
i'm like i just want to support it
because it's just all about having fun
and i'm all about having fun so
they're really good marketers mm-hmm i
liked it too it's like oh you want to
learn more just add it to cart and enjoy
that's funny so getting you one for your
birthday it is
five by five i'm getting him five for
his birthday it's forty five dollars
oh just yeah there's more pattern so you
could have more of a pattern like why
don't you just wear a speedo
i'm gonna do that and put it on my only
fans no so they're saying that um
it's to make your package look bigger
because it rides it up
like my dick goes all the way to my
shoulder you just can't see it i don't
need that i don't care if a package
looks big or not i
don't care yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
either i don't care about that cold
outside i tuck my [ __ ] in
and then plus growers i mean yes yes
growers
tend to have better erections anyway so
really
yes oh growers yes girl shop showers
yeah the showers apparently i don't know
how true this is
but apparently they have less of a
stronger uh erection because
um the growers like their their blood
more blood going in here yeah
and then the rocks your dick size is
already your dick size whether or not
you're right i get it now
i get the context yes yes yes yeah one
is like a small balloon and you're
force feeding air into it and the other
one is already a sack
tighter hair balloon like when it's soft
it's
already its size yeah yeah yeah i see i
think i think that saying comes out
because us growers want to feel better
about ourselves
so yeah well i mean i i i think because
when i see a shower
cause i'm a girl right if i see a show
or a little intimidating and it's
in its limp form it's like already three
times bigger than i could ever become
i'm like even a record for a girl
there's some big ones that are crazy big
shoulders are scary
from my own perspective my own personal
opinion i do like a grower because i'm
like i don't know what i'm going to get
surprised you know with the show where
it's like you're already halfway there
so you're like well how much bigger can
it get
you know because it's already [ __ ]
big yeah because some of them already
have i mean they can get bigger but i'm
just like
it's just fun it's kind of like a chia
pet like you just see it like crap
like the time that's it
what is it like it's kind of like an ego
trip for some girls where it's like yeah
i made that [ __ ] [ __ ] grow
oh yeah oh that [ __ ] got hard for me
yeah maybe that's what it is
i agree they say every time
like every time it pops up
and it goes back down
[Laughter]
yeah so you're down you guys are down
i'm down you don't even got to ask me
i'm i'm down you know i'm gonna do that
[ __ ] you know where i'm gonna wear this
what size do you wear
medium large that's what i was thinking
what do you wear i think i'm medium
medium yep
i'm getting it or small imagine the tan
line you're going to get later i know
what a weird timeline no problem girls
can get can do it and so can guys
yeah but this looks stupid it's a tarzan
tan line
wearing a bag
i just wish to me though i wish it
wasn't a panty
like it looks like a panty color oh like
a little girl
the pattern or you don't like trolls
yeah it looks like a panty like for a
child
what if it turned into shorts though
that would be kind of cool i was hoping
it'd be leather
i'll make a request i'll send an email
to their customer service because i
would wear that in a [ __ ] cape
rock that [ __ ] your superhero
oh there's only two um yeah there's only
two designs an apple
and i don't know man but they're right
though we gotta come up with some new
stuff let me do it
do we have two mingos and pineapples i
thought what you guys had was pretty
good
we have constant new stuff all the time
there's the amphibious shorts for
barbell brigade make sure you check
those out
quick drying quick drying scene stretch
yes
but there's a fine line between straight
sexy and gay sexy
for guys right like you could it's like
there's a lot of
clothes out there that um
it can it can go one way really quick
because it's like when you see like a
guy that's like
like mr romance hot and he's trying to
be
all hot for like the ladies it's
different
from the gay dude the cuts that they
wear what depends if you're
talking about european style or us no
because
when you you watch like all the i mean
you'll be on a sex shop or something
looking at lingerie right and then
whatever
and then like the guys want there's
clearly gay biker stuff like he'll be
having short shorts with no
butt parts you don't mean like they're
like it's a short short
but there's nothing in the back so no
like traps
it's assless shorts you know that's not
for that could turn on some girls you
don't know
you don't know what people are into i
don't think that it's for straight women
though
for sure and i don't know most straight
women at least i want to put
i want to put him in that and then put a
leisure on him have him walk on all
right
you don't know that that's what i heard
though i bet there are some people who
are into it
but you're telling me you're [ __ ]
trolling me right now you're telling me
when you see that [ __ ] you get turned on
no right
it's not for you it's for men
well you don't know people are you oh my
god
don't even [ __ ] act like that [ __ ]
turned you off it does not turn me
off yeah but why can't you admit that i
i'm not i mean i am
i am i think we're defending the people
that like you exactly no
i'm saying that there's nothing wrong
with that i'm just saying that isn't it
true that it's not made for women it's
made
mainly for men right and there's a fine
line between the two
because you can get turned off if a
good-looking guy
is not wearing the right thing yeah
right yeah yeah that's what i'm trying
to point out here is that
like there is a there is a there is a
straight sexy that
most women generally will will will like
and then there's another kind of sexy uh
wear that a guy will wear
that it's for other men yeah yeah yeah i
guess this one feels like
it is just for straight trolling
yeah yeah yeah cuz look at that look at
the frequently asked questions it says
should question should i stuff my
brokini answer yes in all caps
question how long will my brokini last
answer hopefully not very long we want
you to buy more
we might have [ __ ] up and used high
quality materials though
question he might have [ __ ] up our
brokini's good for the environment
answer yes they will make everyone happy
around you
and more happy uh question can girls
wear brokenness it's 20 20 i don't see
why not please buy five
is the strap only meant for one side or
can you put it like on the other side
looks like it's only meant for one side
which side do you choose it's up to you
no it's already made it's made it's the
right side what if
so what if her dick yeah what if her
dick curves to the other side yeah
because
if you're right-handed and not
left-handed makes it even what it looks
like on its own oh it's already curves
to the right yeah
that's so funny how they came up with
that design like was it an
accident and then they were like bro
maybe they did look at tarzan
it's just all it is is just underwear
with one suspender
yeah yeah i wish you were closest
or the overalls are you too with the
borat you're right i may have been
closer
i wish it went one over the hip and one
over the shoulder and it showed it
oh like have the open hip yeah okay so
imagine like you want to put it
this way but it doesn't go on your left
thigh that's funny
there you go guys your next design you
can bro
it's a bong that's what it is it's not a
thong it's a bro thong
it's good it's a brong it's a bra
[Music]
you